sardinen natürlich sardinen die gehören
zu jedem volksfest in lissabon und auch
sonst soll bitte alles wieder wie immer
sein nach drei jahren feiert lissabon
santo antonio
tanja korea ist 34 hier im stadtteil
moravia geboren und arbeitet sonst als
hausmeisterin hat sich aber den juni
frei genommen um am fest stand ihres
sportvereins dabei zu sein wir feiern
unseren schutzheiligen diese tradition
gibt es schon seit sehr langer zeit
während der pandemie ist ausgefallen und
deshalb ist die rückkehr dieses festes
für alle und insbesondere für uns
innviertel hier etwas ganz besonderes
abends geht es für tanja im sport für
einen von moria weiter er bereitet sich
auf die große parade vor corona soll sie
in diesem jahr nicht wieder aus dem
rhythmus bringen
wir müssen lernen mit dem virus zu leben
das geht nicht mehr weg wir müssen
lernen damit umzugehen
das leben muss weitergehen
wir können nicht drei weitere jahre
alles zu machen viele leute haben
darunter gelitten dass es das fest des
heiligen antonius nicht gab
ich rufe vom gesundheitszentrum in st
ich bin erst
maria teresa die mutter an die tochter
isabel ferreira betreut kurve quelle
zunächst am telefon in einem der größten
krankenhäuser der region
portugal hat eine der höchsten im quoten
weltweit verräter beobachtet dass die
zahl der fälle vor kurzem zunahm mit der
variante b 5
es gibt sehr viele fälle ohne symptome
auch weil fast alle beschränkungen
aufgehoben wurden und die leute gerade
bei den volksfesten feiern und keine
masken mehr abwarten
moral ist eines der traditionsreichen
viertel von lissabon der vater soll hier
im neunzehnten jahrhundert geboren
worden sein das volkstümliche spielt
eine große rolle
keystone ab hier habe ich mich
geschminkt in meiner wohnung in
deutschland nahm eine
elena anjos ist 81 und hat in den 60er
jahren mal in deutschland gelebt
ansonsten war sie hier zuletzt allein
seid ihr mann verstarb die steigenden
cupid zahlen beunruhigen sie
in meinem alter da habe ich große angst
aber sie mal morgen um 1 uhr soll ich
die vierte dosis bekommen ich weiß aber
noch nicht ob ich hingehe eigentlich
will ich nicht
in der pandemie waren vor allem die
älteren einsam wer wissen will warum das
fest trotz oder gerade wegen coo wird
bedeutsam ist sollte elena anjos bei
einem der umzüge zu sehen
vielen vielen dank
[Musik]
perfekt
guck mal hier bin ich
dem sportverein von moore aria zu darin
marschiert auch tanja korea mit
[Musik]
ich lebe jetzt seit so vielen jahren
hier und ich liebe so gerne hier dass
ich jetzt anfangen zu weinen
warum denn die an mir vorbeigehen
berührt mich das sehr
der höhepunkt der feiern die große
parade am abend tausende sind auf den
straßen die behörden des landes und
bürgermeister carlos moya schwaben trotz
steigender kurve zahlen in diesem jahr
alle feierlichkeiten genehmigt ohne
auflagen
dieses fest ist ganz wichtig für die
stadt nicht nur für den tourismus aber
vor allem für die lissaboner im prinzip
tanken die lissaboner in diesen tagen
die energie um ein ganzes jahr lang zu
arbeiten etwas zu schaffen die stadt zu
verändern
tico tico singen sie in diesem spiel der
liebe hast du den hauptgewinn in der
lotterie der gefühle gezogen
der hauptgewinn ist für tanja korea und
dem sportverein von moravia die parade
durch die stadt und das sie dabei in
diesem jahr mitmachen können
um mitternacht ist darum nicht schluss
cupid hin oder her
[Musik]
jetzt gehen wir alle zusammen in unser
viertel wir werden feiern und es uns gut
gehen lassen
der umzug ist schon stressig jetzt
geht's zurück nach hause
und die pandemie
an die pandemie denken wir nicht und was
morgen kommt schauen wir mal
tatsächlich auch wenn ärzte sagen die
zahl der neuinfektionen steige wegen der
feiern zu tun sich selbst diese schwer
ein ende zu fordern
ein gleichgewicht ist sehr schwer zu
erreichen ein gleichgewicht zwischen dem
psychologischen wohlsein der menschen
die jetzt ein ventil für ihre gefühle
brauchen und der medizinischen situation
morgen nach der parade obwohl sie wie
sie ja sagte eigentlich keine lust hatte
trifft elena anja stand doch im
impfzentrum
eine wie ich die in deutschland als
krankenschwester gearbeitet hat hat
jetzt angst vor der nadel das geht doch
nicht das finde ich auch aber es ist
immer einfacher die anderen zu spritzen
drei frauen im juni tanja helena und
isabell zeigen wie das leben weitergehen
kann in lissabon mit co witt und dem
heiligen antonius
[Musik]